[Music]
a much larger and more frightening
spider sometimes wanders into our homes
it's strike is so deep it must be torn
from the limb but it's too late
she's been bitten by the Sydney
funnel-web spider perhaps the most
dangerous spider in the world
without medical intervention she could
die within the hour
male funnel-web bytes deliver a powerful
venom known as a Trachsel toxin
the toxins reached the circulatory
system in approximately two minutes
and can kill in 15 symptoms include
mouth tingling twitching tongue profuse
salivating watery eyes sweating and
muscle spasms
after two hours most subside only to be
replaced with respiratory distress and
cardiac arrest
Sydnee funnel webs are easy to spot
large spiders with glossy black heads
and dark brown bodies they're best known
for their massive fangs most spiders
fangs our pincer-like but the funnel
webs are hardened and act like daggers
to work these daggers they must raise
their bodies up and strike down
they strike repeatedly and with enough
force to penetrate a human toenail
you